behaviors coming from men with low
self-esteem EG we call them simps we
call them all kind of funny names now if
you're in the arena where women are
dominant and they're allowed to say and
do as they wish which we have right now
we have platform social media Etc
a lot of men will shy away from their
true self just to appease the women in
the arena because I agree as a man you
want women to attract you it's a natural
things or biological things you know
what I mean so a lot of guys don't have
they don't know how to talk to women
I've experienced it and I've seen it but
I think it's hard for a man because when
you think about it like they're they're
told if they approach a girl the wrong
way their girl can cry as a yeah and so
how are they going to be confident when
they're told many many [__] from the
time they're 12. how did the other men
do it how did The Confident men do it
well because because
um we have a smaller and smaller
percentage of men screwing all the girls
so again women find 80 of men is
unattractive and they only swipe right
five percent of the time on dating apps
so the reason the dating Market's kind
of effed up right now is because four
girls that are fours five six and sevens
are sleeping with the eights nines and
tens and they think they're on that
level and they're not and they're
rejecting the guys that are on their
level because a guy is willing to sleep
with anyone right so but that doesn't
mean that doesn't that doesn't mean
you're that hot what's that why is that
open market that's the difference if you
have time for me
need to add to that as well you have to
remember that women are also breaking up
the homes so the men that would that
would traditionally raise other men to
become men are no longer there because
as we know about 80 to 90 of women that
leave or divorce their husband for the
primary reason being financial reasons
and the second being um infidelity but
infidelity doesn't matter because we
cheat at similar rates so most women are
leaving the men because of financial
reasons and then these men are now
raised by women and then they try to
chase women but women don't know how to
court women so then these men are left
thinking okay my mom told me to be nice
and buy her flowers and then she looks
and then she tries to do that for the
girl she's like the coolest waste man
yeah oh and how are they supposed to
feel confident if they didn't have a man
to like raise them I agree with that I
agree with that I agree with you I do
agree with you as you know when it comes
to masculine confidence it's best it
comes from a man be it your dad beat
your uncle whoever's available to you
and as a woman who has had a strong
relationship with her dad it makes you a
different type of woman on the market
you have a different level of confidence
you have realist more realistic
expectations towards men
um you know there's certain things that
my dad helped me understand as a woman
I'm I'm more forgiving than women in my
age group when it comes to not forgiving
that's the wrong word but
I have a better understanding of the
hardships that men face and I have a bit
more empathy towards their position do
you get what I mean but at the same time
having that understanding with a group
of men who haven't had that nurturing is
still very difficult I've got a question
for you then would you date a simp
wouldn't have the confidence to approach
me
your sympathetic of their position and
obviously you're being raised by your
father if that's had an influence on you
so would you date a Sim being
sympathetic well first of who in my
opinion as if he's not a man it's a type
of ouch wow no he's not a man in my
opinion like if you don't have uh oh
sorry if you don't have certain
attributes then you're not on my radar
so for example I'm not a materialistic
person I don't look for someone with
nice clothes nice things blah blah but I
do look for a man who has logic
Direction knows how so is your answer
now yes no I wouldn't date a Sim okay
right but like if you're sympathetic to
the play Department I didn't say
sympathetic I said Emperor empathetic
okay empathetic why wouldn't you date a
Sim yeah I wouldn't there's no there's
no compatibility there for me I know
that a man with logic Provisions knows
what he's about would fit better with me
so that's why so um question do you guys
think that women date up or down up oh
uh I think depending on age okay so then
then what you say uh I say would you
guys say up oh yeah
so how can we say women are the prize if
they date up and mandate down that's a
good question that's a great question do
you know do you know that's an amazing
question I feel like the generation
we're in now I feel like everybody just
has to stay up because no no everybody
can't no so this is
up someone someone's reaching every
relationship someone likes the other
more exactly someone's reaching
someone's satellite yeah okay yes indeed
I genuinely feel like where we are in
this life here
everything is so difficult yeah
everything is getting lesser and Western
just it's not check your friend zone
yeah
wow that was a good thing yeah but I
feel like a lot of my guy friends I'm
compatible as friends and I'm not and I
don't want to lose that no no no you're
not attracted to them like that or
something you like the attention you
like the attention I think I'm
definitely attracted to some of my guy
friends I just wouldn't want to go there
would they want to go there with you
possibly however I just know that the
boundaries and adverb are treasure the
Friendship I'm not trying to do that
yeah because more time if a relationship
ends up bad I've lost you as a friend
yeah and as that and if I value the
friendship I feel like but it can end up
good what the relationship that's the
risk in it it sounds quite pessimistic
do you really see yourself having a lot
of male friends once you get married is
that really help no no yeah so healthy
That's not healthy That's not healthy
anyways so what's the point of having
them around no but I just thought like I
like in this day and age like you have I
feel like a lot of people are mad so
what do you what do you what do you see
as the problems in the the dating Market
the problems in the data market I feel
like um everything has become so what
can I get what can I get materialistic
and I feel like people aren't looking at
character anymore do you think that's
the men or the women I think I think
it's both so you think it's the matter
also the women I feel like women have
become this which means that the men
don't even care anymore it's like you
want them for maybe materialistic things
quite a few women so it's kind of like
if that's all you look at me for then
all right cool I'll take you your sister
your auntie and then could you explain
that more what do you mean by that what
I mean by that is there's a lot of guys
who let's say faithfulness was something
that let's say 10 years ago was key
right now in this generation it's like
nobody cares or quite a few people don't
care if the guy is faithful or not as
long as he's looking after them so
you've got a lot of men who maybe they
were faithful growing up now it's like I
don't even need to be famous because I
can get the test yeah is that the fault
of the men or the women sometimes it's
the thought of the woman yeah yeah okay
I agree with you oh yeah sorry I
genuinely believe it's the fault of the
women because it's like if you hand them
a silver platter why would they not take
it yeah and why do I need to be faithful
um um spiritual distance
so why did you say women are the prize
then because when you're growing up like
I said from a young age you're pretty or
this or that I think when you get to a
certain age you need to understand you
need to understand the flower of your
youth when it's finished darling
understand this Village however I feel
like
um naturally in your your taught today
up because I just feel like
he just needs to be the head of the
household if that makes sense so the
head would mean he's up yeah so then he
would be the prize yeah but that's
something my answer was when you get to
a certain age I feel like it flips
okay I think let's say 25 and up 25 and
up 25 I think after high school I'll be
honest no I agree with you what would
you think I I think I think men are
always the prize because because the
women the women that men want like when
50 of women that hit 30 are single and
childless so so the most you think men
understand they're the price from Young
I think I think the small percentage of
men do when they have when they have
other doorsteps
like from from the time from the time
kid you know because it's only a very
small percentage of men that get that
and then you know the the women
like the women that won't settle and I
think they're just gonna die alone
no seriously because yeah and they won't
have kids and but fulfill their
biological imperative so you have to
compromise that yeah yeah I mean
somebody went into though yeah but this
is the thing like we compromise where it
always benefits us and never benefits
the man because when we compromise it's
like at 30. literally and that's not
what men want um
when you talked about a dating Market
the old the old women on the panel
believe that women are the problem in
the with the data market
they contribute they contribute 100 they
contribute because there's one can I
just say this yeah there's more women on
the Mark here in the daisy market and
how I would put it is everyone so a lot
of women say they're the prize but they
don't act like a prize so they're
readily available if you're available to
25 men how are you a prize you're
readily available I put it like this if
you have a Rolex they don't advertise
Rolex you know the value of it if you
you see a Ferrari they don't advertise
that you know the value of it if you're
on social stating apps advertising
yourself with no clothes you know trying
to get male attention are you really
apprised but what that sounds like to me
huh that sounds like a cognitive
distance to me so like you think of one
thing but you're not the other so that
still goes back to the fact that women
are potentially the problem in the data
market because of this delusion that
they they carry I'm the prize yeah I
deserve this and I deserve that yeah
really I'm not actually the fighter like
how can you be a prize at all if you're
a virgin if you're not a virgin
in the 1950s like like you were a hoe If
you if you slept with like two people I
think men nowadays would pray for two
and so it's like like how are you a
prize if you're not a virgin and so
you're well